what we know about medicine is always
changing on a day-to-day basis I mean
just last year they got metabolism wrong
they came out with this big report that
said we'd always thought it was slowed
down in age and it doesn't slow in age
that's kind of a basic part of our
health and that and you can read stories
like that almost year to year they've
also got depression wrong oh it wasn't
the serotonin okay I'm not saying it's
corrupt although there is quite a bit of
that too
somehow when it's the Sackler family
with the opioids it's like oh see
corporations and pharmaceutical
companies but when it's covered oh no
they must have everything on the up and
up okay but say it's not mostly that
they were trying and they did a great
thing they came up with a vaccine which
many people most people needed and saved
millions of lives that's true too Robert
Kennedy may not agree with that but your
point is entirely correct bill which is
I think a lot of people have forgotten
how we got to be successful in the west
and part of that is freedom of speech
and freedom of research right especially
inside science especially in medicine we
need people
to be able to talk about the facts and
when you have some kid who works for
Twitter in the Philippines censoring a
Nobel prize-winning scientist in his
speaking about his era of expertise I
think we've lost the plot right one
final point on this is the number of
people who are wearing t-shirts that
said I believe in science science became
this thing that was the conventional
wisdom coming from the government from
the CDC I believe in that that's what
they're talking about you cannot believe
in science science is a process right
it's always changing right and people
thought I could believe in science they
thought it never moved and they were
surprised when it died and that's the
thing the left the far paranoid covet
left talks about science like its
religion the science yeah while they're
doing things like wearing masks alone
outside yes the science
[Laughter]
panel think of Steven Spielberg saying
he regretted replacing guns with walking
oh yes in the walkie-talkies in E.T yeah
he he re-edited to E.T and now he's
regretting that and I'm so glad he is
he's saying movies were made of a
certain